economía en directo América me acompaña
en el estudio Jorge Hurtado Jorge muy
buenas noches comenzamos hablando del
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
que reconoció que su ley para combatir
el cambio climático tiene fallas Cuáles
son bueno recibe el presidente Emmanuel
macron y durante una conferencia
conjunta dijo que en la reunión que
sostuvieron en la oficina oval hablaron
bastante sobre las inquietudes europeas
en torno a esta ley biden dijo que sus
esfuerzos por crear puestos de trabajo
en Estados Unidos no pretendían ser a
Costa de Europa macron ha dejado claro
sus inquietudes y la de otros líderes
europeos también en torno a esta ley
antiinflación que favorece según ellos a
las tecnologías estadounidenses para
combatir el cambio climático en áreas
Como por ejemplo la fabricación de
vehículos eléctricos macron aplaudió las
gestiones de la administración de biden
para combatir el cambio climático pero
aseguró que los subsidios representan un
retroceso para las compañías europeas
escuchemos que respondió el presidente
estadounidense
no hay nada fundamental nunca se
pretendió cuando escribí la legislación
nunca se pretendió excluir a la gente
que estaba cooperando con nosotros esa
no era la intención la intención era
asegurarnos que ya no estuviéramos en
una posición cuando hubiera una pandemia
en Asia y China decidiera que ya no iba
a vender los chips de ordenador
pasamos ahora a México allí el salario
mínimo aumentará para el año entrante
buena noticia para los mexicanos bueno
el aumento será del 20% pasará de 8,6
dólares diarios a 10,35 dólares diarios
así lo confirmó Luisa María alcaldes
secretaria del trabajo de México para
los municipios de la frontera norte de
ese país el sueldo básico pasará de 13
dólares a 15,6 dólares la decisión
ocurre en medio de la inflación mexicana
más alta en dos décadas que alcanzó en
septiembre pasado una tasa anual del
8,7% es el índice más alto desde el año
2000 pero blackrock la mayor gestora de
fondos del mundo prevé presiones
inflacionarias en enero y el de Los
sueldos preocupa porque podría generar
mayor presión de costos en las empresas
escuchemos es decir que a partir del
primero de enero se incrementará su
poder
y con ello también dará dinamismo a la
economía local al mercado interno y se
apoyará no solamente directamente a los
trabajadores sino a sus familias
seguimos con temas de América Latina
porque en Venezuela a pesar de la
flexibilización de las sanciones por
parte de Estados Unidos la petrolera
Chevron dijo que no va a ser mayores
inversiones En ese país así lo dijo
Michael with el presidente de esta
petrolera Estados Unidos emitió la
semana pasada una licencia de seis meses
que permite a Chevron aumentar la
producción de petróleo y ampliar sus
operaciones en Venezuela Chevron es la
última gran petrolera estadounidense que
sigue operando en Venezuela a la empresa
le deben más de 13 mil millones de
dólares por dividendos y deudas de sus
empresas mixtas con la petrolera estatal
pedevesa pero la reactivación no
supondría un impacto relevante en la
producción global así lo dicen los
economistas
falta global de petróleo son 100
millones barriles diarios Venezuela no
llega con su producción y a un por
ciento de esto y digamos que lo que
estamos estimando como impactos de lo
que podría aumentar la producción no
llega ni al 2% de la oferta global ahora
bien si estamos viendo en el tablero
global que hay como un reacomodo y esas
exportaciones que antes iban a Asia
pueden ir a los Estados Unidos hablemos
ahora de Divisas el euro se apareció
Supongo frente al Dólar después de la
publicación de datos de la economía de
Estados Unidos el euro superó los 1,5
dólares respecto al Dólar también
apoyada por los comentarios del Powell
de la reserva Federal de ese país que
apuntó a una subida de los tipos de
interés menor en diciembre la
rentabilidad de la deuda del tesoro
estadounidense a diez años cayó por
debajo del 3,60% también esto ayudó al
Euro con cierta distensión en los
mercados financieros porque China relajó
de alguna forma las restricciones contra
los brotes de covid 19 durante la
jornada la moneda única europea se
cambió en la banda de fluctuación entre
el uno coma tres dólares y 1,5 dólares
Jorge una noticia que me preocupa hasta
el precio de la cerveza aumentará en el
2023 preparémonos a todos en realidad
Así lo anunció heinek en la empresa que
afirma debe enfrentar el costo de los
insumos y del aumento del precio de la
energía la segunda mayor cervecera a
nivel mundial dijo en un comunicado que
tiene la intención de aumentar los
costos de manera razonable este aumento
de costo será más visible sobre todo en
Europa eso es una buena noticia para los
latinoamericanos contiene ese continente
vive una crisis energética consecuencia
de la guerra de Rusia en Ucrania la
cervecería holandesa espera volúmenes de
crecimiento modestos o estables dijo
para el próximo año Bueno entonces por
acá tranquilos Jorge muchas gracias por
este reporte del mundo de la economía a
continuación el debate en directo
América